bonjour moi je
veux pour votre fonction ben non non ma
patience sa femme le nom ils ont fait un
gros effort cette année c'est pas un
plaidoyer à brive ou touché combien et
bien ça y est je suis à 300 francs voyez
non non non je veux pas faire comme
certains qui abusent non non c'est pas
pour la pension à c'est pour votre
logement alors pas bon ça va bien aussi
je me renvoyaient j'ai une pièce voyez
avec baugé la place de mon livre monkey
chevet loyers non mais ça vous bien me
dire que ça vous suffit oui ça me suffit
vous savez j'habite au 18e étage et j'ai
pas d'ascenseur à l'orangé et un touché
alors ça va bien pour le logement c'est
pas question des loyers vous avez des
enfants vous voyez pays sont drôlement
jeunes qui avaient vous voyez par
exemple qui vient de m'envoyer eh ben
ils passent toujours chez le boucher
avant lui demande s'ils n'ont pas un
petit coup de mou wade bunker un petit
bout de quatre jours benoît renaud ce
qui viennent vous voir souvent au bas
d'une double comme le mieux qu'ils
peuvent ouvriers parce que voyez bien
cette année selon lui trois fois et ils
habitent loin et oui ces constats
voiliers sont moins hauts au moins
quatre stations de métro de chez moi
au nom jamais faut bien des efforts non
non je n'ai pas tout ça parce que vous
vivez toute seule eh bien justement
voilà on y arrive j'ai un ami à une
aventure
clairefontaine amis
me et loeb alors vous venez pour lui
alors je mets pour lui et pour moi c'est
pour nous vous voyez pas ce que parce
que voilà je vous le dis comme c'est un
peu plus
on ya fait plus + 6 ans il peut plus à
faire il peut plus du tout
vu alors je vais à boissy à votre niveau
vous pourriez fait que très pauvres
c'est à dire la madame voyais je suis
quand même impuissance
il va y avoir une épidémie moyens
mais qui manque la cible
mais bon après madame b oui c'est libre
vient pas un secours ben oui on va je
suis dans une situation financière
catastrophique où la mort de bouddha
tout de suite en 1984 on en est tous un
petit peu là
y à écouter mal à moi moi c'est une
série de catastrophes mais alors des
catastrophes catastrophe une chaîne en
chaîne continue madame une vraie série
noire alors d'abord je suis tombé malade
ou salées en 84 gelé tous un petit peu
malade entre nous entre nous oui oui et
pas moi ben moi je suis resté trois mois
à l'hôpital quand même pour mac au pain
l'essor j'étais chez ma soeur mais là
bas et c'est qu'est-ce que ça le prénom
de votre soeur monique espère qu'il peut
ennuyer vend pas on verra quand
je vous dis la vérité maintenant mais
alors je suis resté chez ma soeur en
compagnie des cent seulement ma soeur
elle a un gros chien voyez alors bon le
chien dormait dans la cuisine mais en
face c'était gênant envoyé surtout
qu'elle aime beaucoup sabelt alors elle
l'a carrément quand je suis dehors quoi
c'est bien normal à votre à sa place
du fait de mon absence de trois mois
j'ai perdu mon travail oui bah vous
savez ça c'est pareil à cette année
c'est ça aujourd'hui je suis ici de
machines en bus roulent à côté elle ça
c'est en ça pour comble de malheur ce
matin j'arrive chez moi
les voleurs ont tout fracture d'où ils
m'ont tout emmené même les fenêtres au
filet voleur mais y en a partout c'est
vous qui vous ont tout lamier qu'est ce
que c'est mais reste sam hannah murray
ce qui ne nous mettons pas tout emporté
quand même alors qu'est ce qui vous
reste qu'à lens de petits sacs alors oui
tout va la prendre comme ça mais
pourquoi est ce qu'il est bien sûr jean
du vieux pantalon pour d'autres ou
délavés ben youssef et où paris prend
trop bien comme ça et j'aime ça et vous
avez le coeur à m jean rouger plus rien
rien du tout et vous l'avez vous le
prendre s'avoue soulagé qu'il n'y a rien
dans cette sacoche alors pour qui ce qui
est d'autant mieux que pour ça ça va
avec on se reprend aussi c'est bon alors
qu'est-ce qui a d'autres mais faut
vraiment rien rien qui puisse
acheter pour mon ami puisqu'il est jolie
qui tombe les signets
ou désigné iris ligne et qu'est-ce qui
règne chez moi tu vois non pas chez moi
il m'a plu avec eux rien vu que j'ai pu
résister mais voilà lorsque je pense que
je vais faire ça vous dépanner je vais
le prendre il y aura très bien chez moi
non pas comme ça ça sera bien voyez ça
va nous soulager ne l'est plus rien
l'invasion louvière partir complet vous
repartez à 0 0
écoutez je repasse à la maison ainsi
reste quelques bricoles un oui à lorsque
vous fait je pensais vous prend le
plastique mais je vous garde et le
plastique est ce qu'il reste deux trois
bricoles vous revenez mais je replace
d'accord je compte sur vous au quai aux
rivaux
bonjour je vous vois je ne vous demande
rien voilà je dispose d'un petit peu de
temps dans mon planning et voudrait
faire du bénévolat à baisser très bien
madame
c'est très bien madame il ya de tant de
gens qui ont besoin je les aime très
consciente madame bon alors je regarde
ce que j'ai alors j'ai une crèche au jeu
cross très très fort avec les gosses
bien malin bon alors vous vous présentez
de ma part demain à 6 heures du matin oh
là là là ça va pas faire du tout ça
alors bon qu'est ce que vous avez à
partir de 11h matin
alors à partir de 11h 11h30 nous avons
un restaurant pour les anciens - vous
avez un service à faire leur service à
la française ou anglaise à la louche
madame
alors ça se présente eh bien vous vous
présenter à la presse que je vais vous
indiquez il vous remettra aux un tablier
plastique couleur je vous arrête tout de
suite plastique les matières
synthétiques a vraiment je fais des
irruptions gênait pas qu'une sorte
vous pouvez faire un peu d'animation
peut-être du mal an il faut leur parler
ah oui non alors je suis pas assez pas
causeries je suis pas content à tout ça
alors j'ai un centre ici un centre de
sourds muets à aubervilliers non mais
c'est pas mon quartier c'est pas mon
quartier c'est à écouter javid avenue
foch alors c'est au moins une heure
thaksin chez moi vous prenez les
défraiements ocha au nom de ma poche
pour pas exagérer non plus d'en écouter
leur encontre quartier je ne vois qu'une
chose organisé par la spa dans le rôle
de l'homme de 5h à 6h et vous pouvez
promener de gros chiens des bâtards bons
alors accordé voilà ça y est je crois
que j'ai bien sûr et la chose voilà ce
que je pense est-ce que vous avez une
garde de chars de 5 à 6 non les charges
mais pas mon canari non non non je n'ai
pas faim qu'à l'arrivée on va vous
pouvez toujours faire passer une annonce
bien voilà c'est ce qu'on va faire mais
voyez je savais qu'on allait cependant
suis très motivé je ferai ma mère basée
sur ma veste y voilà quelques semaines
je vous aurais je crois que ça va aller
vers s'ils vont très bien on va remettre
est très très chaude
bonjour madame bonjour à l'homme j'ai vu
votre affiche est là vacances pour tous
alors je me suis dit ginette format
plein les calmes de ton bitume wallon
par les bailleurs tourner vous avez
raison madame tout le monde a besoin de
voir le soleil puisque le soleil voit
tout le monde bon bah je vais pas vous
déranger longtemps à parce que là le
temps c'est de l'argent comme dit mon
pierrot un bon [ __ ] des choses que je
n'ai pas très bien compris voyez ces
quads et gîte rural ruraux ruraux ça
veut dire quoi ça un gîte rural des
gîtes ruraux ah ouais c'est comme à
l'école ici un aval des veaux une totale
des taux thomas
pourrions alors c'est quoi gîtes ruraux
rural rural la ferme en méditant
pourquoi vous êtes grossir avec moi bah
je vous parle poliment moi je viens
juste pour demander des renseignements
pour mes vacances pour passer mon monde
était dans un gîte ruraux rural rural
alors mais ça suffit c'est pas parce que
vous avez la structure niveau qui vont
monter sur mon grand cheval ou non
ça suffit je vais j'y vais pour mes
vacances j'ai perdu mon temps d'un cours
du soir aux noms mais avec la vie que je
veux moi vous savez j'en ai jusque là
y'a des fois je me projette très dans le
canal voilà on manque d'air on est tous
je suis comme un poisson hors de son
local voit très bien on a envoyé lui me
comprenait
mais c'est vrai moi j'ai besoin j'ai
besoin d'un peu de sortir de suivre rené
parce que nous on est des cas où vous
voyez on n'est pas des cas ballon à
bagnols assez fière mais sarah ya des
exceptions donne à voir il suffit de se
moquer des gens comme avant n'est pas d
animal
je sors du remix année sa ducati vendu
qu'un animal aux braves à la brava là
pour une assistance aux sur un chat pâle
[Applaudissements]
la porte est bien fermée là
oui madame la porte est bien fermée dans
ce placard
yapaka fnaca a fermé comment y a
personne non madame n'a pas l'habitude
de mettre des personnes dans les
placards
qu'est ce qui n'a pour votre service
malin parce que je voudrais pas qu'on
nous écoute quand même une personne mais
nous non non non et puis on est tenu par
le secret professionnel
alors qu'est ce qui vous amène et bien
voilà
les délégués sont encore passés chez moi
les délégués les délégués des délégués
syndicaux non non ça c'est pas les pires
au nom les grands déléguées et délégués
et ils ont changé toute la minuterie
chez moi ils ont déplacé tous les
interrupteurs de 20 cm à vous voulez
dire le personnel de l'aider elle qui
est passée dans votre immeuble qui veut
faire des travaux à l'eau dès que je
sors ils en profitent ils déplacent tous
les interrupteurs ya ralentir la semaine
dernière maintenant madame mais vous
savez ça pour longtemps ces travaux un
niveau revenir dans quelques jours ils
vont tout mettre en place à vous savez
moi j'ai eu un changement de compteur
c'est assez long mais faut pas vous
inquiéter madame moi j'ai écrit à
françois
à françois à françois mitterrand pour
pour les minuteries où les délégués bien
sûr et il vous a répondu
et des juifs voilà
voilà les accusés de réception
pas lui il est au courant de toute façon
le chômage l'inflation tout ça c'est les
délégués
bien sûr il le sait mais il peut rien
faire et vous pouvez faire quelque chose
vous
pour l'inflation monopoly de léguer aux
bains vous savez si françois n'a plus
rien à faire moi
assez embêtant parce qu'il y en a de
plus en plus vous n'avez pas remarqué le
soir dans le métro comme des gens ils
ont l'air crever ainsi dépassé les
délégués
la première nouvelle dit john parce
qu'ils ont des émetteurs bond alors il
les en place à ça fout le cafard aux
gens non bah oui quand vous passez dans
tout le cafard
il faut se méfier puis une minute
d'inattention à
lui sa [ __ ] chez vous mais quand même
mais bon maintenant voyez on est toutes
les deux ici à voyez s'il ya personne à
c'est comme si vous me disiez qu'il ya
quelqu'un sous la table qu'est ce que
vous faites là
que vous faites là quoi jeter les fagnes
appâter les fans ici la norme éditeurs
jouent bien à part tout madame vous avez
raison
visionnement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]